la situation tragique en corée du nord
où sont affamés des centaines de
milliers d'hommes et de femmes victimes
de la pénurie du pouvoir aujourd'hui
l'association action contre la faim a
décidé de quitter le pays
considérant qu'elle n'avait plus de
marge de manoeuvre descente jérôme bunny
hiver à nouveau très rude en corée du
nord avec pour les plus démunis
un seul souci qui tourne à l'obsession
survivre loin du regard du monde
les paysans se nourrissent de grains de
riz ou de maïs glanés dans les champs il
traverse des temps très difficiles il y
à peu d'électricité
les coupures sont fréquentes il y a peu
de chauffage du fric on prend en compte
ils manquent de nourriture ils ont froid
et ils ont pas fou chocraux conclu
depuis trois ans les familles n'ont fait
plusieurs centaines de milliers de morts
en corée du nord
la maigreur des enfants leurs lésions
cutanées sont des signes évidents de
malnutrition eux ont la chance d'être
hospitalisé mais dans des établissements
sans chauffage ni médicaments le cuisine
on prépare une mixture des corses
d'arbres d'herbe ou d'algues ça fait des
pâtes qui remplissent l'estomac un
défaut de vraiment nourrir
derrière ces famines il y a bien sûr
l'effondrement de l'union soviétique
principal fournisseur d'énergie qui
entraîna un bond en arrière de
l'agriculture il ya surtout la dernière
dictature stalinienne qui consacre
l'essentiel de ses ressources à l'effort
militaire face au frère ennemi la corée
du sud
l'aide internationale arrive mais c'est
l'état qui la contrôle et la distribuer
de façon discrétionnaire les
organisations humanitaires n'ont pas
leur mot à dire nous travaillons dans
des crèches ou les enfants étaient bien
vêtu bien nourris en bonne santé et tant
mieux mais à la fois nous voyons si dans
les rues de la ville on nous travaillons
les en france salle vêtu de haillons
vivant près de la gare et nous ne
pouvions pas porter assistance à ses
enfants là et cela c'était vraiment très
regrettable
nous avons essayé de proposer aux
autorités un programme de soupe
populaire pour la fois contrôler notre
aide et venir en aide aux populations
les plus démunies
malheureusement ce programme a été
refusé après deux ans sur le terrain
action contre la faim de guerre lasse
quitte la corée du nord ces derniers
mois les tentatives des puissances
occidentales pour rompre l'isolément du
pays n'ont rien apporté à ceux qui en
ont le plus besoin